ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVIN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN. BENNETT
BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN. BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN. SUSHI
THIS AREA WHEN O'DONNELL LISTEN
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TAKING BALLOT AREAS THE
APPROVED WHAT VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE DAYS PRIOR
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY A FAMILY MEMBER BRIAN. SARAN.
ALMIGHTY GOD. WE STAND IN YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY EMPOWERED BY YOU
AND BY THE PEOPLE HAVE CHOSEN
US TO REPRESENT THEM. AT A TIME
WHEN MANY TO GET
RESPONSIBILITIES GREATER THAN
THEMSELVES. MAY WE ALL CHOOSE
TO RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
THOUGHTFULNESS. COMMITMENT AND
PURPOSE BECOMING OF THIS BODY
IN OF THIS GREAT STATE. IT'S
BEEN SAID THAT SERVICE TO
OTHERS IS THE PRICE WE PAY. FOR
OUR TIME HERE ON EARTH. HELP US
ENSURE THAT ARE WORKING TODAY.
AND OVER THE COMING WEEKS.
REFLECT THE UP MOST IDEALS OF
THAT SERVICE. TRULY THERE'S NO
GREATER. CALLING IN THIS
MORNING ON THE. THANK YOU
MISTER BRYANT WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG THIS IS A- WHICH IS AN-
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE. PROBLEM
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
LIVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
TUMOR SACRAMENTO MONDAY JUNE
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS FROM THE MINUTE ONE PM
AVAILABLE FOR S. MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS FOR THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HOLDEN AND
WOOD. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. AND I
MEDICALLY OR ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
DAVIES GABRIEL AND ROBERT RIVAS.
ISRAEL'S YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MISSIONS THANK YOU MADAM.
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW MYSELF. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS RAMOS MAYES SHOOTING
MEDINA AND WEEKS TO SPEAK IN
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AROUND I DON'T BELONG PLEASE
MOVE ITEM FIFTY SIX SB FOUR
EIGHTY STERN TO THE AN ACTIVE
FUN. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM SEVENTY SB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT HERTZBERG FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SIT ASSIST BAND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA. AND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE SB THREE THIRTY DID ALSO
FOR HEARINGS ON TUESDAY AND
WEDNESDAY RESPECTIVELY. PENDING
SUSPENSION OF JOINT RULE FIFTY
SIXTY ONE. AND PENDING RE
REFERRAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THIS
PRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE
TO CORRECT MY LAST MOTION. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA AN ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
AND THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB THREE
THIRTY DID ALSO. FOR HEARINGS
ON TUESDAY AND THURSDAY
RESPECTIVELY PENDING SUSPENSION
OF JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE AND
PENDING RE REFERRAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE ACTION
WHEREBY ON JULY EIGHT SB FIVE
SIX FOUR CORTESE WAS READ THE
THIRD TIME PASSED IN ORDER TO
THE SENATE. PLEASE ORDER THE
BILL TO THE THIRD READING FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO. I ITEMS FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE SB TWO NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
TWO NINETY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE MR
LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB TWO NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALSO WOULD CREATE A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
OPERATOR EXCAVATOR WHO AFTER
FAILING TO FOLLOW DIG ALERT
REQUIREMENTS. DAMAGES A
SUBSURFACE INSULATION CAUSES
THE RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS GAS OR
LIQUID I'M SURE THIS ALL WITH
YOU NOW SO I DON'T HAVE TO DO
IT WHEN ACTUALLY COMES UP FOR A
VOTE. THESE ARE JUST TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS- IN NATURE IN OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM CAL
FIRE EXPECT THAT FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER GREEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT BACK ON
FILE. WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM
THIRTY TWO SB FIVE FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR
WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE. MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND AMENDMENTS. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AMENDMENTS TO
SENATOR LAYERS SB FIVE FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MR STAND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM FORTY
ONE S. B. TWO NINETY TWO FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY TWO WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PURPOSES AMENDMENTS GOOD
MORNING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE PRISON OFFICE
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL TWO
NINE TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WILK REGARDING INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CULTIVATION AMENDMENTS ALIGN
THE DEFINITION OF THE TERM
DISPOSAL WITH INFECTION AB ONE
THOUSAND OF THE FOOD AND-
AGRICULTURE CODE. TO THAT OF
DEFINITION OF NINE NINE ZERO
ONE OF THE TITLE SEVEN OF THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO REARRANGE THE
BILL SECTIONS. TO NOT CHAPTER
OUT PROVISIONS WITHIN THE
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY ONE A
TRAILER BILL SIGNED INTO LAW
EARLIER THIS YEAR I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL OF SAY NO. THE
EYES IT THE AMENDMENT ARE
ADOPTED HOW TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE. WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM
FORTY TWO SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
FOR PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS BY SOME REMEMBER THAT
YOU. MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE ALSO
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SP
SEVEN SEVEN NINE THESE ARE NON
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS. THAT
SIMPLY RESOLVE A CONFLICT WITH
THE BUDGET BILL AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WITHOUT OBJECTION- TOOK A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT. HOW TO
PRINT AND BACKGROUND THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT
IMPACT ON FILE. WE WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN S. B. TWO
THIRTY NINE FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENT THE COOKERY SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY NINE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED PURPOSES AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB TWO THIRTY NINE IS THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE BILL. THE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSTRAPPING ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO THE AYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT
IN BACK ON FILE. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
SIXTY
THREE THREE SIXTY SIX. MEMBERS
WE WILL NOW MOVES TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS
WILL BE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX S. B. TWO SEVENTY
THREE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
CENTER HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AN
APPLE INTO WATER QUALITY.
CENTER PARKING IN YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA FINDS
ITSELF STARING DOWN ANOTHER
CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND THIS TIME
IT'S YET ANOTHER DROUGHT.
NEARLY FIVE YEARS AFTER OUR
LAST HISTORIC DROUGHT
CALIFORNIANS ARE EVER
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT.
AVAILABILITY OF WATER AND THE
CONDITIONS OF DROUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
DROUGHTS ARE GROWINGMORE
FREQUENT AND SEVERE. TO ADDRESS
THIS CALIFORNIA MUST ADOPT
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS EVERY
SOLUTION WE HAVE. SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE AUTHORIZES MEN
YOU MUNICIPAL WASTE WATER
AGENCIES TO ENTER INTO
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS WITH
ENTITIES RESPONSIBLEFOR STORM
WATER MANAGEMENT TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE STORM WATER
AND DRY WEATHER RUNOFF.
STORMWATER IS A HIGHLY VALUABLE
RESOURCE THAT IF CAREFULLY
MANAGED CAN AUGMENT OUR WATER
SUPPLY WHILE IMPROVING WATER
QUALITY ENHANCING ECOLOGICAL
HABITATS AND REDUCING FLOOD
RISKS. WELL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD BENEFIT FROM STORM WATER
CAPTURE AND REUSE THEY OFTEN
FACE SEVERAL BARRIERS TO
FINDING AND MAINTAINING
STORMWATER PROJECT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY GRANTED
THIS AUTHORITY TO SEVERAL
MUNICIPAL WASTE WATER AGENCIES
BUT ONLY THROUGH PIECEMEAL
LEGISLATION SB TWO SEVENTY
THREE ESTABLISHES A UNIVERSAL
STANDARD AND THAT'S INTERESTED
NO ENTITY HAS TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE ASK FOR PERMISSION.
TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR WATER SUPPLY THIS IS THE
KIND OF RED TAPE WE AS A
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE REMOVING
IN CALIFORNIA FOR CREATIVE AND
IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS. THE NEXT
BIG DROUGHT IS HERE LET'S
PASSED THIS MEASURE AND MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO PROVIDE
CLEAN WATER TO CALIFORNIANS THE
MEASURES ARE C. BIPARTISAN
VOTES IN BOTH HOUSES AND I REST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MACINNES BARKING SEEING NO
MEMBERS OF OUR- THIS RUBIO HE
RECOGNIZED. ISRAEL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM HONORED TO
pE. R. ELEVEN WHICH ESTABLISHES
THE CANCER PATIENTS BILL OF
RIGHTS WHETHER IT'S A FAMILY
MEMBER A FRIEND MITHRAEUM SORRY
ARE WE ARE ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SIX I'M SORRY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HE SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL WILL MOVE TO THE
VOCAL OPEN ROLE. MEMBERS DIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED.
MEMBERS WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS THIRTY SEVEN
THROUGH FORTY WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEMS FORTY ONE FORTY
TWO WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS FORTY THREE THROUGH
FORTY SIX. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN S. C. R. ELEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY
CENTER RUBIO AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE CANCER PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS. RUBIO THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I AM HONORED TO
STAND HERE TODAY AND PRESENT AS
THE R. ELEVEN WHICH IS FABULOUS
SHE HAS THE CANCER PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS. WHETHER IT'S A
FAMILY MEMBER A FRIEND OR WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT PERSONALLY
MOST OF US HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY CANCER. FORTUNATELY AMAZING
AMAZING INNOVATIVE ADVANCES IN
CANCER SCIENCE ARE CREATING
MORE EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND
CURES FOR PATIENTS. WHILE THESE
ADVANCES IN CARE ARE LIFE
CHANGING THERE ARE ETHNIC AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC DISPARITIES IN
CANCER OUTCOMES. ALIGNED WITH A
LACK OF ACCESS FOR THESE
CUTTING EDGE TREATMENTS AND
CLINICAL TRIALS. THE RIGHTS OF
THESE PATIENTS TRANSCEND BEYOND
ECONOMIC STATUS AND ETHNICITY.
CANCER PATIENTS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO RECEIVE THE MOST
ADVANCED TREATMENT DESPITE.
DESPITE INEQUITABLE BARRIERS
THAT LEAVE THEM MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE FROM THEIR INITIAL
DIAGNOSES. S. R. S. C. R.
ELEVEN PROCLAIMS CANCER
PATIENTS SHOULD HAVE A KEY
RIGHTS SUCH AS BEING
APPROPRIATELY INFORMED ABOUT
THEIR DIAGNOSIS TREATMENT
OPTIONS AS WELL AS TIMELY
ACCESS TO CANCER SPECIALISTS
AND THOSE WITH EXPERTISE IN THE
TREATMENT OF THEIR CANCER. THIS
RESOLUTION IS SUPPORTED BY A
NUMBER OF PATIENT AND PROVIDER
GROUPS INCLUDING THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY CITY OF HOPE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES CEDARS
SINAI. THE MYELOMA FOUNDATION
AND THE CHRONIC CARE COALITION
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS IMPORTANT CANCER PATIENT
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAYES RUBIO DR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
IN THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION TO
THE FLOOR TODAY. AND SENATOR
RUBIO FOR AUTHORING THIS
RESOLUTION. SOME ARE AWARE THAT
BOTH MY FATHER AND BROTHER WERE
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER WITHIN A
MONTH OF EACH OTHER. SO I KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW THE DIAGNOSIS OF
CANCER CAN IMPACT NOT ONLY A
LIFE OF THAT INDIVIDUAL PERSON
BUT THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
WELL REMARKABLE ADVANCES IN
CANCER SCIENCE ARE CREATING
MORE EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND
CURES FOR PATIENTS EVERY DAY.
THERE ARE STILL MORE THAT CAN
BE DONE TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
CARE. MANY CANCER PATIENTS DO
NOT BENEFIT FROM THESE
TREATMENT ADVANCES AND SOME DIE
NEEDLESSLY AS A RESULT. THIS
RESOLUTION ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
CANCER CARE IS DIFFERENT AND
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED IN SUCH.
THE PRINCIPLES INCLUDED IN S.
C. R. ELEVEN PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF ALL CANCER PATIENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS VERY
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN CANCER CARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR EVER
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS OUR
RIGHTS AS A CO AUTHOR AND
STRONG SUPPORTER S. C. R.
ELEVEN. IN CALIFORNIA CANCER
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH BEHIND HEART DISEASE AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
WHICH RUNS MORE THAN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND YOU
CANCERS CASES WITH NEARLY SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND DEATHS. WHILE
SCIENTISTS CREATE A MORE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND CURES
FOR PATIENTS AFFECTED BY
CANCER. MANY CANCER PATIENTS
STRUGGLED RECEIVE LIFE SAVING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE BETTER
ACCESS TO CANCER CARE INCLUDING
THE RIGHT TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
DIAGNOSIS AND BE INFORMED
WITHOUT ABOUT TREATMENT OPTIONS
IN KERALA THE APPROPRIATE AND
UNDERSTANDABLE LANGUAGES I HOPE
YOU JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING S.
YARD EVAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GIVE MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE AND
I RISE AS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
ACR SKEWS ME UP S. C. R. ELEVEN
CANCER PATIENTS BILL OF RIGHTS.
MEMBERS ALMOST ONE POINT NINE
MILLION NEW CANCER CASES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE DIAGNOSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE AN
APPROXIMATE SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHT. FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS ARE EXPECTED
TO LOSE THEIR LIVES DUE TO HIS
BATTLE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE. MY SISTER. WHO IS
BORN RIGHT AFTER ME. IS PART OF
THE ONE POINT NINE MILLION NEW
CANCER PATIENTS CASES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS PERSONAL TO
ME. BECAUSE GETTING THAT CALL.
FROM HER TO LET THE FAMILY KNOW
SHE HAS CANCER AND STATES FOR.
MY STOMACH JUST BLEW OUT. MY
HEART START RACING. AND I
STARTED IMMEDIATELY VERY VERY
SCARED. I CAN'T LOSE MY SISTER.
I CAN'T LOSE HER. AS A SOME OF
CALIFORNIANS ALMOST THOSE BACK
TO THOSE VULNERABLE AND
DISADVANTAGED CANCER PATIENTS
DON'T HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
CUTTING EDGE TREATMENT. AND
CLINICAL TRIALS REGRETTABLY
COVERED COVERAGE DO NOT
GUARANTEE THAT A CANCER PATIENT
IS ABLE TO ACCESS EXPERT CARE.
THIS RESOLUTION INCLUDES
IMPORTANT RIGHTS THAT EVERY
CANCER PATIENT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD EXPECT FROM THE TIME
THEY'RE DIAGNOSE. IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF RACE
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS EACH
PERSON HAS EQUAL CHANCE TO BEAT
THIS DISEASE THAT IMPACTS SO
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY AND LOVE
ONES I AM PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL COLE. OF S. S. C. R.
ELEVEN AND I'M DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CANCER
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE THE BEST TREATMENT
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO WIN THIS
BATTLE LET ME SIMPLY SAY THIS
IS I CLOSE I'M GOING TO ASK
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO
PRAY FOR MY SISTER HER NAME IS
ROSE AND I'M NOT ASHAMED TO SAY
THAT. IT ALSO PRAY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BATTLING WITH THIS
DISEASE AS WELL THAT THEY WILL
BE A WINNER THEY WILL BATTLE
THEY WILL WIN THIS. OF
DIAGNOSIS AND BEAT THIS CANCER
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON MR
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I STAND TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF. THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE S. R. ELEVEN.
MOST OF US HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY CANCER WHETHER IT'S BEEN.
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER A FRIEND
OR PERHAPS EVEN HAD TO FACE A
PERSONALLY. THIS RESOLUTION
PROCLAIMS THE CANCERS PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS AND DECLARES A
CRITICAL. PRINCIPLES OF CANCER
CARE SHE PROVIDED TO ALL CANCER
PATIENTS. MANY OF THESE
PRINCIPLES SHOULD BE THE STATUS
QUO. SUCH AS ENSURING THAT
CANCER PATIENTS ARE INFORMED
ABOUT THEIR TREATMENT OPTIONS
AND CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
UNDERSTANDABLE LANGUAGES. MANY
CANCER PATIENTS UNDERGO PAINFUL
TREATMENT. ONE OF THE
PRINCIPLES CONTAINED HERE IS A
CANCER PATIENTS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO MEDICAL TREATMENTS FOR PAIN
MANAGEMENT. CALIFORNIANS CAN
AND SHOULD RECEIVE BETTER
CANCER CARE. EVERY PATIENT
DESERVES ACCESS TO THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT PLACE AND
FROM THE RIGHT EXPERTS. S. R.
ELEVEN AS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
PATIENT HAS THE RIGHT TO TIMELY
ACCESS TO TREATMENTS THAT WILL
HELP THEM FIGHT THE DISEASE AND
I ASK FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
AKADEMISK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF S. C. R. ELEVEN WHICH CREEK
PROCLAIMS PUT SPECIFIED
PRINCIPLES AS THE CANCER
PATIENTS BILL OF RIGHTS. CANCER
CARE IS COMPLEX AND REQUIRES
ACCURACY OF INITIAL DIAGNOSIS
CHOICE OF THERAPY AND ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE CLINICAL TRIALS.
THERE HAVE BEEN ADVANTAGES IN
CANCER SCIENCE LEADING TO
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND EVEN
CURES. HOWEVER ETHNIC AND
SOCIAL ECONOMIC DISPARITIES AND
ACCESS TO QUALITY QUALITY
CANCER CARE RESULTS IN MANY NOT
BENEFITING FROM THESE ADVANCES
I TOO LOST A BROTHER AT FIFTY
YEARS OLD TO CANCER.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
AND DISADVANTAGED CANCER
PATIENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
APPROPRIATE TIMELY ACCESS TO
SPECIALISTS SUB SPECIALISTS
CUTTING EDGE TREATMENTS AND THE
RIGHT TO BE FULLY INFORMED AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR DIAGNOSE.
THEIR DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
OPTIONS PLEASE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF EQUAL ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
BY SUPPORTING S. C. R. ELEVEN
THANK YOU. THINK HERE THREE
SEVEN. THIS IS JANUARY CAN I
SEND A MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I. RISE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN URGING SUPPORT
FOR S. C. R. ELEVEN BUT WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT IS IT
JUST A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
AND AS SUCH IT CONFERS NO
ACTUAL RIGHTS TO CANCER
PATIENTS SO AS A FIRST STEP I
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
BODY DELIBERATING A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY CONFERS RIGHTS. TO
CANCER PATIENTS. THANK YOU MR
STERN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MAYES RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK- FOR NOT AYE
VOTE AND ASKED THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR- COBBLERS. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
COOPER. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.ÔIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT THERE ARE
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
WELL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE FIRST
PASS AND RETAIN. THE REMAINING
ITEMS WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FORTY EACH
THROUGH FIFTY SIX WE DISPENSE
WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AND
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT. NOW MOVING TO
A VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEMS FIFTY NINE THROUGH
SEVENTY FIVE ALTHOUGH I WILL
AGAIN NOTE WE ARE PASSING
ENTERTAINING ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE THROUGH SIXTY SIX. DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SCENE HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ. SO NO MEMBER WANTS TO
MOVE ANYTHING MAKING CALENDARS
SO THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT SO THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDARS WILL FIRST OPEN THE
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORSHIP OF THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SOMETHING CURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS RELATIVE TO GOLD
STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES DAY
THIS IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY
ARTS- AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE TOMB OF THE UNKNOWN
SOLDIER. ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAY AUTO AND
OTHER POLITICAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION WEEK ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY RELATIVE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO BY SENATE
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PARKS AND
RECREATIONAL PROFESSIONALS
MONTH. THE CLERK WILL- OPEN THE
ROLE FOR. ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS TO CO AUTHORED
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. AGAIN THIS IS
TO CO AUTHOR THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE THERE ARE SIXTY EIGHT
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS
ON TODAY'S CONTENT CALENDARS WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR. AT
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOLUTION SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS RELATIVE
TO GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES THERE. WILL OPEN THEIR
OWN CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VOTE. WHERE WILL LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN HI SEVENTY TWO NANCY
ALLISON THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO SUM THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY EIGHT. ZERO
SENATE BILL TWENTY SIX WITH
URGENCY FIVE SEVENTY TWO NOTED
THERE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS HERE ON THAT MATTER
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO NINE ZERO SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY FOUR I
SEVENTY TWO ZERO SENATE BILL E.
THIRTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NEWS
HERE SENATE REALLY FOURTEEN I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SAN
ABILITY TWENTY FOUR. SEVENTEEN
OH ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO I
SEVENTIES YOU KNOW THEIR ANSWER
THE BILL FOR FIFTY THREE HI
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTIETH
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY THIRD. FOR
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW TO ENSURE
IN MY- PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR COM. OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY I ASK THE PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. OFF THE FLOOR.
YEAH.
YEAH. MYSTERON US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN MEMORY FROM US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I RISE I
RISE TO REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF CONGRESSMAN
JERRY LEWIS. WHO ON JULY
FIFTEENTH AND REDLANDS- PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY SIX.
WE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
CONTINUE TO OFFER PRAYER. THE
INLAND EMPIRE IS PACKED WITH
THE RESULTS OF HIS DECADES OF
SERVICE TO OUR REGION. IN
ADDITION TO A SERVICE TO THE
STATE AND THE NATION. HE WAS
ENTHUSIASTIC UCLA ALUMNI. SO
MUCH SO THAT WHEN WE VISITED
WITH- CONGRESSMAN LEWIS AND HIS
OFFICE HE WOULD BRING HIS
BELOVED DOG OUT OF BROUGH AND
TO MEET WITH THOSE THAT WERE
VISITING WITH HIM. BEFORE HIS
ELECTION TO CONGRESS HE SERVED
THE INLAND EMPIRE. AS ASSEMBLY
NO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF TRUSTEE MEMBER. SERVED
ON THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. AND SERVED
IN THIS ASSEMBLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HIS LEGACY
INCLUDES SECURING FUNDING
FEDERAL FUNDING. FOR A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY. LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY'S PROTON BEAM
TREATMENT CANCER ROOM AND
FUNDING FOR SEVENOAKS TREE
CLEARING IN THE SAMMOBILE
NATIONAL FOREST WITH THE BEETLE
BARK INFESTATION AND FUNDING TO
THE MODERNIZE OF THE ONTARIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. MR LEWIS
HAS ALSO BEEN A GREAT FRIEND.
TO OUR PEOPLE ON THE SAN MANUEL
INDIAN RESERVATION AS WE
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE WITH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
A GREAT CHAMPION FOR INDIAN
ISSUES ACROSS THE COUNTRY. HE
WAS ONE OF MY STRONGEST
SUPPORTERS WHEN I GOT INTO THE
POLITICAL ARENA IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD AND THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
ULTIMATELY HERE. CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS IS PASSING. RESULTED AND
MANY TRIBUTES FROM UP
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY N. UP IN
THE UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
ARLENE. BROTHERS RAY AND JOHN
FOR CHILDREN JENNIFER JERRY
JUNIOR JEFF AND DAN AND
NUMEROUS GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. HE IS A
PILLAR THAT MAKE SAMBAR DINO
WHAT IT IS TODAY THE WHOLE
COUNTY AND GIVES US ALL THAT
OPTION AND THAT HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
BETTER OUR COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUE TO WORK AS PEOPLE NOT
SO MUCH WITH PARTY LINES IN THE
FIRST PURVIEW BUT WORK AS
PEOPLE TO BETTER PEOPLE'S LIVES
IN SAN MARINO COUNTY. FOR THAT
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF CONGRESSMAN JERRY
LEWIS THANK YOU MISTER AMASIS.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE CITY REMEMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK
THAT WE JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES IN ASKING THAT
THIS HOUSE ADJOURN THE MEMORY
OF CONGRESSMAN JERRY LEWIS.
JERRY LEWIS WAS A LIFELONG
PUBLIC SERVANT STARTING OFF AS
WAS NOTED AS A MEMBER OF THE
SAMBAR TO DINO SCHOOL BOARD A
MOVING ON TO SERVE IN THIS
HOUSE AND THEN EVENTUALLY TO
CONGRESS. HE WAS THE LONGEST
SERVING REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND
CHAIRED THE POWERFUL HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WE
CONSIDER JERRY AND ARLENE OUR
DEAR FRIENDS. MANY MIGHT BE
SURPRISED TO LEARN THE DURING
HIS TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY HE LED
THE EFFORT THAT ESTABLISHED THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BECAUSE
EVEN IN THOSE DAYS YOU COULD
ALREADY SEE THE EFFECTS OF
SMOG. IN OUR COMMUNITY. JERRY
LEWIS APPROACH PUBLIC SERVICE
ON THE FOUNDATION OF BI
PARTISANSHIP WHERE HE WORKED TO
GET VITAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT BECAUSE THEY
WERE REPUBLICAN IDEAS OR
DEMOCRAT IDEAS. BECAUSE THEY
WERE NEEDED. REGARDLESS OF
PARTY AFFILIATION OR POLITICS
JERRY WORKED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INLAND EMPIRE RECEIVED ITS
FAIR SHARE. JERRY'S LEADERSHIP
IN FACT WAS KEY IN PROVIDING
THE FIRST FUNDING FOR HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTIONS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE AND SINCE THEN. IT HAS
GROWN FROM THE TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS INITIAL MONEY TO TODAY
BEING NOW OVER ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE MILLION. JERRY LEWIS
EXEMPLIFIED THE DOING WHAT IS
RIGHT FOR YOUR COUNTRY AND
DOING WHAT IS RIGHT FOR YOUR
DISTRICT IS BIGGER THAN PART
PARTY AFFILIATION AND POLITICS.
HE IS REMEMBERED FONDLY IN
WASHINGTON DC AND ACROSS THE
INLAND EMPIRE FOR HIS YEARS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE. I ASK THAT THIS
HOUSE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF OUR FRIEND AND OUR
REPRESENTATIVE JERRY LEWIS.
THANK YOU MISS FRANCISCO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS
INTERMINABLY. CALLERS I JUST
WANT TO RISE I ACTUALLY RECALL-
JERRY LEWIS TURNER SERVICE IN
THIS HOUSE. HE HAD JUST A
TREMENDOUS. FRIENDLINESS ABOUT
IT OBVERSE ALLOWED GOING I HE
WAS A VERY INFLUENTIAL MEMBER
JUST FOR THE POWER OF HIS
PERSONALITY IN THIS COLLEGIAL
BODY. AND I ALSO THINK HE SORT
OF A MARKER HE ENTERED THE FACT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS FOR A
TIME DISRUPTED AND IN AN
ALTERED QUARTERS WHICH OF
COURSE IS NUMBER SO THAT WE SEE
FACING US IN THE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. AND SO I DO REMEMBER
HIM IN THIS CHAMBERS IN THE
TEMPERATE CHAMBERS ON THE SIDE
OF THE BUILDING. BUT- YEAH I
JUST VERY DISTINCTLY RECALLED
JERRY LEWIS AND HIS PRESENCE IN
THIS BODY AND SO THE NEWS OF
HIS PASSING STRUCK ME IN A
DIFFERENT SORT OF PERSONAL WAY
SINCE I KNEW HIM AS A YOUNG
MAN. SO I JUST. AN HONOR TO
JOIN IN HIS MEMORY THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER WILLIAMS MAYES
YOU ARE. THE MINISTRY CARE INTO
MEMBERS TODAY I ALSO WANNA JOIN
MY OLLEAGUES- IN ASKING THAT
WE DURING THE MEMORY OF
CONGRESSMAN JERRY LEWIS. WHO
DEVOTE ONLY REPRESENTED AT THE
INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITIES FOR
FORTY NINE YEARS AT AT AT EVERY
ENTRY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING HERE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY HE WAS A PUBLIC
SERVANT IN THE TRUEST SENSE OF
THE WORD. I I GOT ELECTED TO
THE YUCCA VALLEY TOWN COUNCIL
WHEN I WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD I'LL TELL YOU WHEN I WAS. A
TWENTY FIVE I LOOKED UP- TO
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS IS THE GUY
WHO I WANTED TO. TO EMULATE
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS WAS MY
CONGRESSMAN I WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN MY
PARENTS MOVED. OUT TO YUCCA
VALLEY FROM FROM BACK EAST IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE WHEN HE
GOT ELECTED AS A CONGRESSMAN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND HE
WAS MY CONGRESSMAN. UP UNTIL HE
RETIRED IN IN IN TWENTY TWELVE.
AND YOU CAN HEAR THE COMMENTS-
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHETHER.
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT OR A
REPUBLICAN- YOU ADORED HIM- HE
WAS A BELOVED BACK IN
WASHINGTON DC HE WAS BELOVED A
BACK HOME AND HE DIDN'T MATTER
TO HIM. WHETHER YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN WHAT
MATTERED TO HIM- IS WHETHER YOU
CARED ABOUT THE COMMUNITY AND
WHERE YOU YOU CARED ABOUT- THIS
THIS COUNTRY. I SO WISH THAT WE
COULD GET BACK IN THE FILL ALL
OF OUR STATE HOUSES AND BACK IN
WASHINGTON DC WITH LEADERS LIKE
A LIKE LIKE CONGRESSMAN LEWIS.
I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US
TO BE ABLE TO REMEMBER HIS LEG
LEGACY AND HOPE TO EMULATE
EMULATE HIM. AND AS WE MOVE IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU MR MAYOR
THANK YOU OFFER MEMBRANES AND
IMPORTANT MEMBER WHO SERVED OUR
COMMUNITY SO GREATLY. WITH THAT
WE WILL WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL WILL NOW BE LIFTED
AND REMOVED THE ADDITIONAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MR CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF
SO MANY AND SAN FRANCISCO IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE HEARTBROKEN.
I RISE IN THE MEMORY OF JANICE
YOU'RE A TINY THE FORMER POET
LAUREATE OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND
THE HEART OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WHO LOST TOO SOON.
JANICE WAS A TEACHER AND ARTIST
AND ACTIVIST. WHOSE COMMITMENT
TO EMPOWERING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. LITERALLY
TRANSFORMED THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
BORN IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE AND
STOCKTON. SHE WAS INCARCERATED
WITH HER FAMILY AT AN ARKANSAS
CONCENTRATION CAMP DURING THE
MASS INTERNMENT OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
UNFORTUNATELY HER LIFE REMAIN
HARD AFTER SHE WAS RELEASED
FROM INTERNMENT CAMP IN
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. SHE MOVED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS A YOUNG
GIRL. AND INJURED EMOTIONAL
ISOLATION. POVERTY AND SEXUAL
ABUSE. IN THE YEARS THAT
FOLLOWED SHE CHANNELED HERSELF
THROUGH POETRY EVENTUALLY
BECOMING OUR CITY SECOND POET
LAUREATE. SHE RENDERED THE RAGE
OF THE OPPRESSED THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVOR AND THE
INVISIBLE ON TO THE PAGE WHILE
ALSO EXPOSING THE RAJOY OF
SPEAKING THE TRUTH. WHAT WAS SO
INSPIRING ABOUT HER WAS HER
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO HELP
OTHERS STRUGGLING AT THE
MARGINS. TO HELP OVERCOME THEIR
OWN CHALLENGES IN THE WAY THAT
SHE HAD DONE FOR HERSELF. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE SHE CAME TO
WORK. AT GLIDE MEMORIAL CHURCH
IN SAN FRANCISCO. BECAME ACTIVE
IN THE ANTI WAR PEACE AND HUMAN
RIGHTS MOVEMENTS. AND THAT'S
WHERE SHE MET. HER FUTURE
HUSBAND. THE REVEREND CECIL
WILLIAMS AND HELP TO CO FOUNDED
GLIDE FOUNDATION. BUILDING THE
AMAZING COMMUNITY THE GLADYS.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DO NOT
KNOW GLIDE. IT EXEMPLIFIES THE
VERY BEST OF THE VALUES OF
CHRISTIAN FAITH. OF HOW WE NEED
TO BE RADICALLY INCLUSIVE. JUST
AND LOVING TO ALLEVIATE
SUFFERING. AND BREAK THE CYCLES
OF POVERTY AND MARGINALIZATION.
CHANCE EXPOSURE THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE TO THE INJUSTICES OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND SEXISM
PARTICULARLY AGAINST LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS PROPELLED HER
ACTIVISM AND HER DETERMINATION
TO PROVIDE A LOVING HOME FOR
EVERYONE IN OUR CITY.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER SHE
RECEIVED OVER FORTY AWARDS AND
HONORS FROM EVERYONE. IT WOULD
TAKE AN HOUR TO LIST THEM- BUT
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT%
HER LEGACY OF UNWAVERING
ADVOCACY FOR COUNTRIES MOST
MARGINALIZED INDIVIDUALS. LIVES
ON IN THE CITY OF SAINT
FRANCIS'S SPIRIT OF COMPASSION
AND GENEROSITY. AS ONE OF
THOUSANDS WHO HAVE ATTENDED
RECENT SERVICES FOR HER. I CAN
ASSURE YOU SHE WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED SHE WILL ALWAYS BE
LOVED. SHE WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. AUSTIN POWER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SEARCHING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
GERMAN MEMORY. I ALSO MONITOR
RISE TO ASK OUR BODY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF JANICE BETONTE. OF
MY COLLEAGUE- MY- COLLEAGUE AND
I HAD THE HONOR OF ATTENDING
HER MORAL OVER THIS WEEKEND
WHICH WAS SENT OUTSIDE IN FRONT
OF GLIDE MEMORIAL CHURCH. IN
THIS CHURCH IS MY COLLEAGUE
JUST ARTICULATED. IS REALLY
ABOUT UNCONDITIONAL LOVE IT'S
ABOUT HELPING AND MEETING
EVERYBODY WHETHER OUT. IT'S
ABOUT WELCOMING ANYONE WHO
NEEDS WHATEVER HELP THEY NEED
INTO THEIR OPEN ARMS. THE
CHURCH IS IN A VERY CHALLENGING
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH IS A BLOB I
IRONICALLY A BLOCK FROM. MANY
OF OUR NICE HOTELS AND ONE OF
OUR AND ONE OF OUR CENTERS OF
OUR TOURIST LOCATIONS. BUT IN
THIS IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD. YOU
HAVE SO MANY FOLKS WHO ARE
HOMELESS. SO MANY FOLKS WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR THEIR NEXT MEAL. SO
MANY FOLKS WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
A SENSE OF PLACE. AND FOR
FAMILY IN FOR LOVE. THIS CHURCH
IN THIS ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN A
BEACON. THEY WELCOME EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU ARE. WHAT
YOU STAND FOR WHICH I BELIEVE.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR PAST
REGARDLESS OF YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY HAVE BECOME
A MODEL NOT JUST RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION BUT A SOCIAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATION TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE BY THE
HOMELESS SHELTER. THEY HAVE
YOUTH SERVICES THEY ARE ONE OF
OUR MOST TREASURED SAN
FRANCISCO INSTITUTIONS. JANICE
BAKER TOMMY IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
DRIVING FORCES OF MAKING THAT
INSTITUTION NOT JUST THE PLACE
THAT IS RECOGNIZED IN SAN
FRANCISCO BUT IT'S REALLY AT A
CHURCH. THAT IS RECOGNIZED
WORLDWIDE IT'S BECOME QUITE A
DESTINATION FOR. MANY OF THE
WORLD'S CELEBRITIES. IT'S
FAMOUS BECAUSE SIDE DURING THE
AUCTION- WARM BUFF IT OFFERS A
LUNCH- ON THE AUCTION THAT GOES
FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHENEVER YOU YOU TO COMES INTO
TOWN THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
GLIDE MEMORIAL CHURCH AT ALL
THEIR CONCERTS. BUT IT REALLY
REPRESENTS A PLACE. THAT IS.
ALL ABOUT UNCONDITIONAL LOVE
AND ABOUT THE HEALING POWER OF
LOVE AND BECAUSE OF GENESIS
LOVE NOT JUST FOR HER COMMUNITY
PER OUR CITY OR STATE WE ARE A
MUCH BETTER PLACE AND WITH THAT
IASK THAT OUR ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU BOTH I TAKEN MY OWN
TEACH IN THAT AND CONDITIONAL
LOVE SO I KNOW WHAT WHAT. MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR NEXT ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE IN MEMORY OF ANOTHER
GIANT TO SAN FRANCISCO JAMES
HORMEL. OUR COUNTRY'S FIRST
OPENLY GAY AMBASSADOR AND
PROLIFIC PHILANTHROPIST. PASSED
AWAY LAST WEEK AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. INVESTOR MEL WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
MINNESOTA AND WANT TO EARN HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
SWARTHMORE COLLEGE BEFORE
MOVING TO SAN FRANCISCO IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. FOR
SEVERAL DECADES BEFORE HIS
APPOINTMENT HE WORKED IN
BUSINESS AND AS A DEAN OF
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO LAW SCHOOL. HE HAD AN
IMPRESSIVE RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THROUGH PUBLIC
SERVICE AND PHILANTHROPY.
INCLUDING PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO ORGANIZATIONS SERVING PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY HIV AND AIDS.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND BREAST
CANCER SERVING ON THE BOARD OF
THE FOUNDATION OF THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN. IN NINETEEN
SET NINETY SEVEN HE WAS
NOMINATED BY PRESIDENT BILL
CLINTON TO BECOME THE UNITED
STATES AMBASSADOR TO LUXEMBOURG.
HIS NOMINATION WAS MET BY AN
INTENSE TWO YEAR. OPPOSITION
CAMPAIGN TO BLOCK IT. DURING
THIS FIGHT HE WAS UNFAZED HE
MET WITH SKEPTICS ONE ON ONE
THE CHALLENGE THEIR OPPOSITION
UNTIL IS ULTIMATELY APPOINTED
TO THE AMBASSADOR SHIP IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. STARK
MOMENT FOR LGBTQ COMMUNITY. HE
HAS RECEIVED MANY AWARDS IN HIS
LIFETIME INCLUDING THE SILVER
SPUR AWARD FOR CIVIC LEADERSHIP
FROM SAN FRANCISCO SPUR AND A
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM
THE HUMAN RIGHTS CAMPAIGN. I
WILL ALSO MENTION A BEHALF OF
OUR ARTS COMMUNITY HAS LOVELY
ARTS MADE HIM A FIXTURE INNER
CITY. WHERE HIS LEGACY OF
PUBLIC SERVICE EQUALITY FOR THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY WILL LIVE ON
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. ON
BEHALF OF OUR LEGISLATURE. WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND FOR YOUR COURAGE.
GODSPEED MR AMBASSADOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER KING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU MA'AM CHARM
ALSO HONOR TO RISE. IN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND JIM HORMEL.
I HAD THE HONOR OF SPENDING A
FEW WEEKS IN ISRAEL WITH
AMBASSADOR HORMEL ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO. AND AT THAT POINT IT
BEGAN OUR FRIENDSHIP AND OUR
RELATIONSHIP. WHERE YOU SAW
SOMEONE WHO WAS NOT JUST A
TRAILBLAZER. A TRIP AND A SAN
FRANCISCO CIVIC INSTITUTION. HE
WAS IN LGBT LEADER NATIONALLY
BECAUSE OF HIS FIGHT TO BECOME
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY AMBASSADOR
IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY. BUT
HE WAS ALWAYS SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE HE WAS MAKING A HUGE
IMPACT. HE WAS THE ONE WHO MADE
SURE OUR PUBLIC LIBRARY HAS AN
L. G. B. T. SECTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE WERE BOOKS IN
HISTORY AND- ALL THE LITERATURE
THERE WAS ACKNOWLEDGED AND MADE
SURE THAT THAT WAS PART OF OUR
CIVIC DISCOURSE. HE WAS SOMEONE
WHO WAS ALWAYS THERE TO BE PART
OF OUR SAN FRANCISCO CIVIC
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER IT WAS
THE ARTS WHETHER IT WAS SAID
THAT EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
OR WHETHER IT WAS OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. HE WAS A LEADER
HE WAS SOMEONE THAT- WHETHER
YOU WERE L. G. B. T. ARE NOT
YOU TURN TO AS SOMEBODY WHOSE
OPINION MATTERED YOU ALWAYS
WANTED HIS ADVICE AND HIS
THOUGHTS. AND HE'S SOMEONE WHO-
HAS LED TO AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST
REITERATED JUST LED AN
EXTRAORDINARY LIFE. AND AGAIN
OUR CITY- WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
BENEFICIARIES OF HIS.
GENEROSITY OF HIS KINDNESS AND
HIS HUMILITY. AND WE ARE ALL
GOING TO MISS SO. PLEASE IF WE
COULD TO TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
JIM HORMEL TODAY- AND JUST.
RECOGNIZE HIM FOR BEING THE
AMAZING TRAILBLAZER THAT HE WAS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR KING MR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS
INTERMINABLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
JOINING I COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WHO ARE. IN THEIR OWN
RIGHT CHAMPIONS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS- PROVIDING. A SENSE OF
GRATITUDE ADD TO. HOME INVESTOR
HAD HORMEL AND A TIME IN WHICH
A WHEN HE WAS. NOMINATED AND
SELECTED AS AMBASSADOR. YOU
COULD STILL BE FIRED IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR BEING OPENLY GAY.
AND IT'S LIKE TO BE THE FIRST.
YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE.
AS A SERVICE MEMBER IN OUR
COUNTRY. I WOULD LIKE TO BE AN
AMBASSADOR REPRESENTING THE
COUNTRY OVERSEAS. MAJOR QUALITY
WAS NOT LAW OF THE LAND YOU
COULD NOT ADOPT IN MANY
COUNTRIES AND MANY STATES. TO
BE DENIED HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FOR BEING OPENLY GAY. AND SO
IT'S PAST SUIT SERVING WITH
DISTINCTION AS- THE FIRST
OPENLY LGBT AMBASSADOR. WAS
REMARKABLE AND WE REMEMBER HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND HIS LEGACY
WILL CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER WELL. MR MEDINA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF GAY CAROLINE WHO PASSED AWAY
IN JUNE AND SERVICES TOOK PLACE
EARLIER THIS MONTH. GATE WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN RIVERSIDE
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN A HUNDRED
AND FOUR YEARS OLD IN OCTOBER.
GATE CAROLINE WAS A LONGTIME
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER AND A LONG
TIME MEMBER OF THE RIVERSIDE
PARK AVENUE. MISSIONARY BAPTIST
CHURCH. HER MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER WERE AMONG THE
FOUNDERS OF PARK AVENUE AVENUE
MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN. AS A YOUNG
WOMAN GAY PLAYED AN ACTIVE ROLE
IN THE N. DOUBLE ACP YOUTH
CHAPTER AND WENT ON TO SERVE AS
VICE PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT OF
THE N. DOUBLE ACP RIVERSIDE
CHAPTER. SHE WAS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT HELPED
ELECT THE FIRST MINORITY
CANDIDATE. JOHNSON TELE TO THE
RIVERSIDE CITY COUNCIL IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. HE WAS ONE OF
FOUR DELEGATES SELECTED TO
REPRESENT RIVERSIDE COUNTY AT
THE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
INAUGURATION OF PRESIDENT
LYNDON JOHNSON. AND SERVED AS
HOSTESS AT THE CHARITON PARK
HOTEL ONE OF THE FOUR INAUGURAL
BALL SITES IN WASHINGTON DC. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE SHE WAS
APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF THE N.
DOUBLE ACP HEAD START STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN RIVERSIDE.
AND FOR SIXTEEN YEARS SHE
ADMINISTERED THE PROGRAM WHICH
GREW FROM FIVE CLASSROOMS TO
TWELVE. AND IN BOTH RIVERSIDE
IN PARIS AND SERVED MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED CHILDREN AT THREE
SITES WITH A STAFF OF THIRTY
EIGHT PEOPLE. HER LEGACY BURNS
BRIGHT IN THE HEARTS OF THOSE
SHE INSPIRED I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HER MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA. NETWORKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
TODAY WE JOURNAL MEMORY OF FRED
IS UNDER A COMMITTED BROADCAST
JOURNALIST AND GENTLE LEADER
WHO PASSED AWAY N JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTH. FRED WAS BORN ON MARCH
FIFTH NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR IN
LAKE PORT CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
GREW UP MILKING COWS ON HIS
DAIRY FARM WITH HIS THREE
BROTHERS. AS A CHILD ATTENDING
SCHOOL AT LAKE FORK UNION
ELEMENTARY HE FELL UNDER THE
SPELL OF A TEACHER WHO HAD BEEN
A NEWS REPORTER. IT WAS THEN
AND THERE THAT HE FOUND HIS
PASSION FOR REPORTING. AT THE
AGE OF TEN HE STARTED HIS OWN
THE NEWSPAPER AT HIS KITCHEN
TABLE. THE SCOTTS VALLEY NEWS
HE WROTE. REPORTED EDITED
PRINTED AND DELIVERED HIS ONE
PAGE WEEKLY. ON HIS EIGHT MILE
PAPER OUT FRED SOLD
SUBSCRIPTIONS CHOOSE PAPER
RUNNING OFF FIFTY COPIES A
WEEK. IN ORDER ITEMS ON DEAD%
COWS AND BROKEN DOWN MILK
TRUCKS. AS A GROUP FREDDIE
TENDED WHEN YOU GROW UP AFRAID
ATTENDED HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY. WHERE HE MAJORED IN
JOURNALISM AND WAS INTRODUCED
TO BROADCASTING THROUGH A PART
TIME JOB AT EUREKA RADIO
STATION. HE WAS THEN DRAFTED
INTO THE ARMY AFTER GRADUATION
AND STATIONED AT FORT BLISS
TEXAS. WHILE STATIONED AT FORT
BLISS FRED WORKED AT A PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER WITH SAM
DONALDSON A TV NEWS REPORTER.
WHO LAUNCH FRED'S CAREER IN
BROADCAST JOURNALISM. HE WENT
ON TO WORK AT KTVU IN OAKLAND
BASED NEWS STATION FOR TWENTY
ONE YEARS BEFORE HIS RETIREMENT
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE. AS THE
NEWS DIRECTOR HE BUILT THE
STATION'S NIGHTLY BROADCASTS
INTO AN AWARD WINNING PROGRAM
IN THE BAY AREA. HOWEVER HIS
LOVE INCOME AND FOR LOCAL
JOURNALISM EXTENDED BEYOND THE
REACH OF KTVU. FOR IT ALSO
BECAME THE FOUNDER OF THE
FAMILY UNDER TIMES AND OUR
OWNER OF THE CASTRO VALLEY
FORM. FREE YEARS HE SPENT HIS
DAYS TIRELESSLY WORKING TWO
FULL TIME JOBS IN JOURNALISM.
ONE IN PRINT AT THE FAMILY IN
OUR TIMES AND ONE IN TV A KHI
TV YOU. JIM KNOWLES MANAGING
EDITOR OF THE CEILING OR TIME
SAID. FRED WASN'T LIKE THE IDEA
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A PUBLISHER
SITTING BEHIND A DESK SMOKING.
CIGARS INSTEAD FRED WAS KNOWN
FOR DOING IT ALL IN BOTH
NEWSROOMS FROM NEWS STORIES
WEDDING ANNOUNCEMENTS. AND
CALENDAR ITEMS TO ACTING AS HIS
OWN PHOTOGRAPHER TO TAKING OUT
THE GARBAGE. AND PULLING WEEDS
IN FROM THE OFFICE. HIT A
REPUTATION FOR ROLLING UP HIS
SLEEVES AND DOING WHATEVER JOB
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO GET THE
NEWS OUT. AND TO GET HIS FREE
PUBLICATION INTO INTO
CIRCULATION. AS COLLEAGUES SAID
HE JUST WORKED. IN WHATEVER
SPARE TIME FRED DID HAVE HE
LOVES SPENDING MUCH OF IT
WALKING OUT IN THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY. TRAGICALLY IT WAS ON
HIS NIGHTLY STROLL THROUGH
CENTRAL MITA THE FRONT WAS
STRUCK AND KILLED BY A DRUNK
DRIVER. HE WAS EIGHTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD. FRED IS SURVIVED BY
HIS THREE BROTHERS JOHN BOB AND
DAVE AND HIS SISTER IN LAW IS A
BILL SEVEN NEPHEWS AND ONE
NIECE. HE WILL BE REMEMBERED BY
THOSE WHO WORKED WITH HIM AS
HUMBLE PASSIONATE HONEST AND
BRILLIANT NEWSMAN- NEWSROOMS
CAN BE HARD CHARGING AND
COMBATIVE IT COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENTS. FRED ALWAYS LEAD
WITH KINDNESS AND UNDERSTANDING
SUPPORTING HIS COLLEAGUES TO
THE BEST THAT THEY COULD BE. I
ASKED WE JOIN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS WORKS MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES THE
DUSTY PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURN IN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING SHOULD BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR CHIU MOVES AND MISS WEST
SECOND FOR THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST
TWENTY THIRD AT ONE PM.